foreign
[Music]
for those who have not been present for
the last few speedrun games in the last
game we faced takarokan I blundered a
piece I blundered a piece
and then we managed to recover and win
bonus okay we're White against decode
I mean again we've been toggling between
jababa London and one E4 but let's
switch back
to our main repertoire and go for E4
especially because we're facing the
center counter also known as the
Scandinavian
which I believe is the first time that
we have faced it in the Speed Run Okay
Knight F6
this is less popular than Queen takes D5
which is the sort of more in the spirit
of the scandi I don't know if Knight F6
has a name apparently it's called the
modern variation uh there is something
called the Portuguese Gambit I want to
say which goes D4 Bishop G4 but many
years ago uh many many years ago around
2005 2006 one of my first coaches taught
me a line uh that essentially avoids a
lot of the theory of the Portuguese
Gambit on some of the trickier lines and
it gives white not as big of an
advantage as you would get if you played
the absolute principled stuff but what I
like is that it just gives you an easy
to play position and it avoids a lot of
the theory so the line goes like this
and I've done this before on a previous
Speed Run I remember that we faced this
you deliver a check on B5 which
shouldn't should make a lot of sense to
you I mean it's a developing move and
you're forcing a piece to appear on D7
which by definition uh is severing the
connection between the black queen and
the pawn on D5 and fundament finally
there are two approaches to playing this
position you could try to cling to the
D5 Pawn so what you could try to do here
is Play Bishop takes D7 Queen takes D7
and C4 and a lot of less experienced
players would gravitate toward that but
I'll show you a couple of analogs after
the game this approach in many openings
is not good because after black plays C6
he attains massive compensation
positionally for the pawn in the form of
dominance over key Central squares and
it's just not an easy position to play
so the movement my coach taught me is to
drop the bishop actually back to E2 the
point is you give away the D5 pawn and
now you occupy the center with D4 and
you get a slight advantage in an easy to
play position what was the point of this
whole operation with Bishop B5 Bishop B2
well it was just a force blacks Bishop
to appear on D7 you might say well why
are we forcing isn't it good for black
to develop a piece well not quite
because the bishop on D7 is a very
awkward piece it's again it's cutting
the connection between the black queen
and the center it's preventing the
knight from accessing that square it's
just not developed on a good Square so
that is why in this line you often see
experienced scandi players actually
reposition the bishop on F5 C5 I've
never seen before it's a very sensible
move my guess is that if we take on C5
black wants to give Queen A5 check and
then pick up the pawn and really contest
our control over the center so there are
several ways that we can fight this move
we can ignore it and just keep
developing our pieces but if possible I
I don't just want to give away our D4
Pawn without a fight now in the alapan
Sicilian there is a similar type of idea
that involves pushing C4 and then
driving the pawn into D5 and
establishing a more a firmer presence in
the center which I think makes a lot of
sense here I think we should go C4 and
counter attack box Knight our opponent
is still playing instantly which tells
me that he probably this is probably
some sort of obscure Theory now here
again D takes C5 is not stupid
because what we could say is okay we're
not trying to win a pawn we're trying to
gain a bunch of Tempe for development so
after Queen A5 check there's one tempo
and then when black takes on C5 there's
another Tempo we could play Bishop E3
and then essentially complete our minor
piece development with Knight F3 so that
I think is a great approach as well
so I like the look of D takes C5 but D5
is what we initially planned to do so I
think we should stick to our guns here
and play D5
A6 okay
so here the Instinct of most people I
think is to play Knight C3
and then to meet Ed with CD but the
problem is that when that plant chain
turns into an isolated Pawn our strategy
loses a lot of its luster because the D5
Pawn becomes more of a liability than a
strength so I think a more prudent
approacher is actually to take on E6
which I know is a little bit
anticlimactic because we did all of this
and now we're just giving away our
Center but if you look concretely it
should make some more sense d e if black
plays Fe well obviously that ruins black
structure we're happy if black plays
Bishop takes E6 then we're able to trade
queens and force Black's King onto a
very awkward Square on d8 which we could
use as fuel for our subsequent
development and you should be familiar
with this General concept where
essentially you're able to castle
queenside with check I'm sure you've
probably done this in other openings and
I think that white has a very small but
a very stable Edge in the end game and
we haven't had that many end games in
general so I wanted an excuse to play an
end game okay clearly this tells me our
opponent is not in preparation this is
just complete Bluff and he's playing
this like a bullet game because Fe is a
very bad move I think now black is
saddled with permanent weakness of the
E6 pawn and of course when black
Castle's King side the king side is not
going to be quite as safe of a place as
it used to be but let's speed up a
little bit I don't want to lose some
time so now the next stage is for us to
just develop our pieces really in any
order I don't think it particularly
matters in what order we develop our
pieces we do want to protect the D4
Square so that black doesn't quickly
establish a knight on D4 but we just do
that by playing Knight F3 let's start
let's start with Knight C3 it doesn't
matter now we'll play Knight F3 gain a
little bit of time and now we'll Castle
we can just basically play automatically
here uh these next couple of moves
but then we should take a moment to
think because this bishop we can develop
it to many different spots and this is
an important decision
where we develop our Bishop I I see at
least four options actually Bishop B3
Bishop F4 Bishop G5 and let's not forget
about the queen side fiancado we can
play B3 and Bishop E2 now let's take the
opposite view what is black likely to do
here well one annoying idea is for black
to try to utilize this Pawn effectively
to push it up to E5 and to establish an
outpost for the Knight on D4 that is a
positional weak well not a weakness but
that is a risk uh that we need to we
need to fight I I don't I don't think we
should allow black to establish an
outpost on D4 because if we trade on D4
then the pawn is replaced uh the Knight
is replaced by a very annoying Pawn much
like our Pawn on Z5 and we won't have
the Machinery available to contest that
pawn so for that reason I like Bishop F4
because it's prophylactic now you might
look at this move and say well I don't
like the fact that we're stepping into
the X-ray of the Rook but an x-ray in
and of itself isn't all that bad we have
to check to see if black has discoveries
unfortunately I think there is what I
would call a positional discovery which
is a discovered attack that is not
intended to win a piece it is intended
to engineer a favorable trade by which I
mean black has this weird move Knight F6
to E4 and after we take on e4 black is
able to eliminate the dark squared
bishop and make it easier for himself to
secure the Knight on D4 so Bishop F4 has
a bit of a I don't know whether to call
it a tactical or positional drawback let
me keep thinking for a minute for a
moment
so if we're not playing Bishop F4 we
might want to resort to B3 we also might
want to play Bishop to E3 even though it
looks a little bit more passive Bishop
to G5 is also possible here from the
perspective of like safest developing
Square I think let's play Bishop G5
let's just play the sort of most
straightforward textbook developing move
and if our opponent plays E5 we'll cross
that bridge when we get there okay
obviously Bishop H4 is the typical
retreating move
Knight H5 which is I I kind of expected
this actually
now let's evaluate this positionally
well positionally it leaves black after
the trade of dark squared Bishops which
by the way we are not forced to engage
in we can drop the bishop back to G3
people often forget about this Prospect
but the thing is then we give black the
bishop pair and this Bishop from E7 can
reposition itself to F6 and again we're
fighting for control of the D4 square
that is the sort of unstated battle in
this position so from that perspective
we should take on E7
and here we need to think what does
black want well black wants at least two
things there is this old idea E5 Knight
D4 it's less scary now because E5 can be
met with Knight to D5 and we get an
outpost of Our Own
the scarier Prospect is Knight to F4
so you might come up with the idea of G3
but G3 weakens our King side a little
bit so I wouldn't want to make this move
unless we were sort of desperate well
not desperate and and really it's not
that weakening
it's really not that weakening because
the dark the light squared Bishop for
black is not able to access key squares
G4 and H3
furthermore after G3 we create this
potential idea of Knight to H4 when the
Knight has access to the forkable square
on G6
three I like the look of a little bit
more than Rook to E1 which would be my
other candidate move here in order to
meet Knight F4 with Bishop F1 which is
another idea that you should absolutely
be fully aware of but I just don't like
the option of allowing the Knight to
land on F4 so I think we're going to
play more drastically here okay our
opponent is still playing instantly and
actually not badly at all I think I'm
I I wouldn't say that white is more than
very slightly better here now the
problem is that if we play Knight H4 I'm
shocked that our opponent saw this that
quickly it took me a while black can
respond with the Knight to F4 and that
is a typical tactic that occurs
sometimes in King's Indian positions
I'll show you after the game Knight H4
Knight F4 and the pawn on G3 is
overloaded if we take F4 we lose H4 and
of course the point of Knight F4 is to
protect the G6 Square so what I think we
should do here is just continue making
small but meaningful improvements to our
position what would those meaningful
improvements look like well first and
foremost I mean we could deploy our rook
and put it on E1 which I think is a
relatively risk-free way of improving
our position now it has its drawbacks in
the form of weakening the F2 Pawn so if
Black's Queen repositions onto the f
file we would have to be careful but
black doesn't do that he plays Knight F6
we need to continue improving our
position
position one move that I kind of like is
Bishop to D3 in order to make space for
our Queen to move into E2 yeah but but
that also puts the bishop in the line of
fire of blackstruck a more measured
positional approach would involve
would involve redirecting our Bishop to
the fianchetto square on G2 which would
solve the problem of some of our King
side weaknesses but is a little bit
passive
hmm not easy actually this is this guy
is incredible let's think about this for
a second
Knight H4 also good but then that gives
up the D4 Square
Queen C2 also interesting yeah I like
the look of Queen C2 to develop the
queen but again that runs into Knight C4
again that runs into Knight T4 and I
don't love that hmm it's a weird
position and white should be better here
but
somehow I don't love it because of this
D4 Square we're struggling because of
the weakness of that square Knight F6 is
an amazing move actually it makes it
very hard for me to find a move
okay I guess Queen C2 Knight T4
CD 94 I don't know why I've been
struggling so much these last few Spirit
games I feel like I'm getting
soundly outplayed
okay let's play Bishop F1
Let's Play Bishop F1
and adopt a more defensive posture
Bishop E8
okay Queen C1 I guess
because again I didn't want to play
Queen C2 because it walks into Knight D4
with tempo
Queen C1 at least if black plays Knight
D4 we have time to react and we can
actually sink our teeth into E5 as a
result
um if black plays Bishop H5 then I think
okay Knight G4 I'm probably getting
crushed here
let's think for a moment Bishop G2 was
the idea
of course that's the whole point of why
we played Bishop F1 in order to get this
bishop to G2 and Knight to D4
okay Knight to D4 I don't find to be
scary actually it looks scary but I
don't think it is
simply because we can take on D4
I think it's a mistake and and now this
scenario looks very scary now you might
be tempted by Rook takes E6 Queen takes
E6 and Bishop to D5 but unfortunately
that tactic fails black and play Rook
takes D5 and When the Smoke Clears black
is simply up a piece you might also be
tempted by Knight D5 but you shouldn't
get distracted we're trying to defend
here Knight to D5
Queen F7 and you can drop the Knight to
F4 but it'll be chased away with the
move E5 so again you want to be
defensive here Knight E4 is the move
because this defends the F2 pawn and on
the next move we might Chase blacks
Knight away with H3
man I didn't know one could play chess
this fast in this well but I learned new
things every day
the white is fine this is probably equal
I really don't know where I went wrong
it feels like I made a mistake somewhere
we'll analyze afterward this will be a
good learning experience for me as well
so there's a move I'm scared of here I
won't say what it is
I'll tell you if yes that is exactly
okay
um because it threatens Bishop before
and Knight takes F2
all right so rookie two D3 Rook D2
okay I'm in serious danger losing this
game so I'm gonna Focus
okay I have an idea
let's go Queen D2
so here's my idea I'm trying to lure I'm
trying to lure black into playing Bishop
takes E4
Rook takes E4
Rook takes F2
and then I'm hoping that what black
doesn't see is that when we drop our
Queen back let's say to E1
black is facing twin threats Rook takes
G4 and it's a classic scenario where if
the Knight moves the The Rook on F2 is
hanging
so no black seems to I think our
opponent is totally legit I mean I am
getting completely outplayed but it
happens
I'm not mistake free I've been saying
that since the start of this video and
I'll probably lose a game you know once
one out of every 500 games I'm going to
get outplayed
so I don't see any reason to be
suspicious yet remember Rook takes G2
King takes you too no no I mean I'll put
it this way if our opponent plays
perfectly the rest of the game
okay then we'll we'll look at it but so
far I've just
I I really I feel like all of my moves
have been very natural and I've gotten
totally outplayed but that just happens
when you make a mistake that's just the
product to make there is a move here
that I'm terrified of
if our opponent plays it I'll tell you
what it is it is a very high level move
it is a very high level move let's see
if our opponent actually plays it he's
probably calculating Bishop takes E4
I won't say the move
just in case I mean I never say like a
move that scares me just just in case
that's just sort of Speed Run policy
yeah this move causes a lot of problems
but it doesn't win I mean it just it
leads to a good position for black but
it doesn't win the game immediately
it's not this move I think Knight E5 was
big problems for white
but no that he seems totally legit to me
so far Rook takes E4 Rook F2 okay so he
goes for this line he goes for this line
and I'm very curious what it is that he
wants probably he wants to sack The
Exchange after Rook takes G2 and go for
I have to record the Warriors game and
go for the weakness of our King
essentially
at least the start of it but I have no
choice we have to play Queen E1 and Rook
takes G2 but I don't find this to be
terrifying and there's two reasons for
that
let me explain the reasons that I don't
find that to be it's scary but not
terrifying
we can bail out and probably we should
bail out
probably we should bail out because our
King is permanently weak the Knight on
E3 is super strong also I realize that
black has Knight to C2 so without
question we have to bail out by playing
Rook takes C3 and queen takes E3 and
white is not worse here I refuse to
believe that white is worse our King is
a little bit weaker than blacks but
black just doesn't have the material on
the Firepower to exploit it Queen F6 is
an excellent move so this has been a
very humbling experience for me but we
go Queenie too defending the B2 Pawn
and the reason I play Queen E2 and not
let's say Rook B1 is because Rogue B1 to
be very passive now we can still try to
win this there's plenty of Chess left to
be played I would be playing this for a
win with black obviously white should
not have any winning chances here if
black plays this normally but I've seen
crazier things in my chess career so
we're gonna I'm gonna try to win this
with white without doing anything crazy
without doing anything crazy
so we could try to play Rook yeah E5 is
another very good move because Rook F1
Queen C6 check
is problematic
but let's do it anyway
Anonymous gifting to stockfish
yeah very very strong I mean I I will
say that
when F takes E6 was played I thought
okay this is gonna be a smooth game but
I greatly under appreciated that move
I greatly underappreciated the move F
take C6 so kudos to our opponent
you know as this is a positional
misjudgment by me I didn't realize how
strong upon was E4
okay probably our opponent is just
playing for a win here so now I also
somehow underestimated this move
okay I guess we have to play B3 to
solidify this Pawn
Queen E6 check
yeah just getting crushed
okay let's think about this queen G4
maybe trying to play for a draw
no this is simply bad King G2 he has E3
which I
failed to see
huh
I mean I will have to go Pawn down end
game and try to say and try to hold it
have to go Pawn down Rook end game only
chance because King G2 E3 I think was
just losing
maybe not but I didn't want to get mated
this is borderline lost but there is
some drawing chances in the end game
actually there are good drawings no no
the end game actually might even be just
a draw
I'm not sure but I think it might just
be a draw
and he doesn't wow he goes through but
but if he gets over ambitious here you
know you can lose control of a game like
this pretty easily actually
I'm stunned that our opponent didn't
trade Queens uh let's think Ricky won
I would take I would take the queen
automatically I'll put it that way let's
try Rook F5
let's try Rook F5
yes I see how much time he has I mean it
doesn't take that much time to outplay
me that's the lesson from this game
Queen E7 Queen F4
I'm teetering on the edge essentially
it's like the dim ding nepo game but
people watching on YouTube I'm recording
this on the on the day of the tiebreaker
in the world championship
so in a in a weird way this game reminds
me of nepoting because black has this
past pawn and it may not seem very scary
at first sight but the path for this
Pawn is totally clear and we really
cannot afford to consign either of our
pieces to a passive existence on like E2
because there's too many other problems
to deal with other than the past Pawn so
what we have to do is basically defend
actively by which I mean we have to find
tactical methods of preventing the
further progress of the pawn I think the
move here is Queen to F4 this I think is
a good defensive move because if black
plays E3 I want to play rookie five and
prevent the further progress of the pawn
rookie eight yeah now we have to get
behind the pawn
with Queen E3 I think
by the way someone's number of games
does not mean anything at all
but again I don't see any reason to be
suspicious I just think he's playing a
really good game
but I'll talk more after the game so
let's play Queen E3 let's focus on
holding this I think I can hold a draw
at least if I'm accurate
I think I can hold a draw at least if
I'm accurate now if Queen E6 then of
course we want to go G4
and this you should understand if Queen
E6 then then we want to go G4
G4
but now I see that
Queen E6 is very good
might be coming to an end we'll see okay
Rogue d8
yeah I'm I'm just I'm getting pushed off
the board here King G2 I have to step
away with my king
I have to step away with my king Rook D3
Queen F4 I'm still trying black can
easily blunder mate there by the way
very easy to blunder some sort of rook
f8 and queen F5 lots of games have
turned around in these heavy piece end
games because one side just gets two and
two enamored with like pushing a pawn
and and leaves the king exposed or even
allows a queen trade and we would
definitely benefit in the event of a
queen trade even at the cost of a pawn
even at the cost of a pawn
okay no Warrior score by the way if
you're watching I know the game just
started but you will get banned
immediately if you share the warrior
score
so please do not share any numbers at
all
Rook D1
so rookie wait a second that actually
looks like a very sloppy move to me Rook
F4 what am I missing I mean I surely I'm
missing something because I I get this
sometimes you get this feeling of
helplessness like it's too good to be
true you know I've been outplayed the
whole game it's funny like I um
have this with super jibs no but he's
he's going astray here I think he's
giving me he's letting me off the hook
pretty easy
he's focused on the wrong pun so
the question now is well we have three
things that we can do if I want to get
really gutsy then we should play A4 and
actually try to keep my queen side pawns
that's if I want to play for the win
then I'll go A4 the problem with the A4
is that he goes Rook a two check and I
can very easily get mated so I don't
the point of the speedrun is to do what
I would do in a real game and in a real
game I wouldn't even think about playing
A4 I would immediately take on e4 and
I'll show you some lines after the game
that are scaring me now what would I
take on e4 with
well I would want to take with a piece
that increases my chances of a queen
trade because the queen trade is the
fastest path to withdraw from this
position if that makes sense and to me
well obviously that would be Queen takes
C4
Rook takes E4 would be the all-in move I
would play in bullet but Rook date I
think Rook takes E4 would be more
appealing to some people because you see
that you can deliver a check on E8 but
if you look concretely after Rook takes
C4 black and play Queen C6 and pin The
Rook against the king also black will of
course start by playing Rook takes A2
check and maybe there we could have
played King H3 yeah maybe that was an
interesting attempt to play for the win
I I didn't appreciate that fully
yeah but okay it's fine
okay now King G3 or King I didn't see
that we could even go King H3 but here
it doesn't make sense to go King H3
because if we're preparing for an end
game we want our King to be as close as
possible to the center
so am I not afraid of Queen to D6 here
painting The Rook against the king okay
now it should be a draw but that doesn't
mean we can't win this I've won some
crazy end games before and if our
opponent gets very sloppy this is a
winnable position now at this point I'm
gonna try to play for a win I'm gonna
try to do everything within my power to
make our opponent go wrong and the first
thing I'm gonna do
is play the move C5
which is a very tricky move and if black
responds inaccurately he is already in
trouble and he responds very accurately
I actually miss this move or does he
yeah he does
okay now let's go Rook D4 and try to get
the Rook to the seventh
I completely missed day five
for some reason I mean it's a
straightforward move because it prevents
Rook before
and that's another very good move um
okay so I guess I'm not out of the woods
just yet let's let's uh yeah I'm still
the one playing for a draw here because
there's a crazy line Rook D6 okay
through here it could be 6a4 now this
net this defensive task it never ends
yeah I guess I'm still in trouble here
just not used to this
okay King F4 I guess
it was not obvious at all actually A5 to
stop like stop it like that with a pawn
was was was far from an obvious move far
from an obvious move
I mean the amount of things I feel like
I'm missing in this game are like
incredible
I it's hard to say if I'm playing
terribly or if he's playing extremely
well probably both okay let's go Rook D6
we'll see we'll see we'll check the
accuracy and stuff I mean he has made
mistakes there's no question that he he
has made mistakes obviously he's made
mistakes
um but overall I've gotten totally
outplayed here King E5 let's try to
activate my king and get this Rook to B6
in order to draw this
okay
yeah I see where this is going
no we're not drawing this unfortunately
I didn't see this movie there
let's try this last Last Hope
Last Hope
I mean if I can go C6 it's still it
still could be holdable
against the you know
a club player but a GM should be able to
beat me here
Rook D2 Rook B2 that's maybe that's bad
no
let's think
wait that's probably not a good move
Rook D3 he allows me to step back with
my rook in order to vacate a square for
my case it's not over it's far from over
Rook G2
okay now I just legitimately have to be
very accurate
okay I guess we're up T4 to Def I mean I
cannot give away a second Pawn if I give
away this Pawn then he gets connected
passers and it's over the game is over
the good thing is I don't have to wait
very long for his move so the torture
won't last very long
Rook g3p4 now Rook G3 B4 that's not
winning I mean that's a trap
that I laid of course he's not gonna
fall for it
maybe he will we'll see
Rogue G3 B4 I want to play
so I'll talk a little bit about the
nature of like suspicion after the game
right now my verdict is that he is legit
and I would say if I was suspicious I
have
I have said it before I will say it
again I truly genuinely think for now
that he's playing honestly he's just
clearly clearly underrated okay so let's
focus on trying to save this
but I'm not sure of course I'm not sure
this entirely I would not be surprised
but I don't believe he is uh let's go
King D6
I don't really know much about Chess and
people so if you think you know better
then I guess you know better
let's go King D6
I think this might be drawable actually
ah but he finds King d8
that's a great move
I I'm just getting this total feeling of
hopelessness
which I shouldn't be getting but I am
getting it
I mean C6 maybe it's a C6
let me think C6 BC Rook A4
is an interesting idea by the way
No it should be a draw let's go see
let's go C6
yeah he does find a lot of good moves
okay BC
Rook a four king C8
King C6
maybe it's lost
okay
hopefully he doesn't play King C and he
gives me the check on D3 then I have
some maybe okay does give me the check
on D3
let's see why that is better
it should be a draw I mean there's
there's no way this should be winning
okay let's go King B7 and then try to go
B6
now wait a second this I I mean I know
it's funny but you know if he's not
careful I can play B6 and King A7 and B7
so I've seen many situations many of
these types of end games where people
just get super flustered and lose okay
that's a good move I think
okay let's go here actually very tricky
move I'm gonna make King B8 the point is
just to roll out the red carpet for the
pawn and the great thing about this for
white is that once I get my Pawn to B7
and I'm actually gonna play for the win
here
no but it's once we get the pawn to B7
then this King on A7 is going to be
unassailable because this Rook on A4 is
stopping Black from delivering checks on
the a file I'm already playing for a win
I'm gonna go King A6
now I think he obviously black can draw
this with super accurate play I already
think black is playing for a draw
and black has a very difficult move here
I see it I think it draws but this
already might be the only move and he
doesn't play what I the move I thought
it was
so now we go B6
and if King C8 King A7 and we're almost
winning
it's probably still a draw though
we're very close to being winning here
King A7
but probably unfortunately still a draw
sag
yeah he finds it
he finds it okay basically actually wait
maybe am I losing
no I I see a draw I think
check will that move obviously wait a
second
Wait Up Wait Up Wait Up Hold Up
there's some cool lines here
Rook C1 A2 nah shoot doesn't work I I
think I have to go B7 because if I go
Rook A4 he can actually start playing
for a win with King C6
so I think
I need to go B7
if my king was on A8 it would be winning
and he finds eight so yeah I mean
there's nothing to find here
yeah and King C7
perfectly executed
but this is a draw
which I am very happy with I have to say
I'm I'm proud to make this draw
because this guy was an absolute monster
and we'll we'll check I mean obviously
here we should analyze with the engine
because okay he's playing for it wait
wait let's not celebrate just yet
now wait a second did that lose no Rook
C1 he's got Rook A3
ah so close Okay but if you go if he
gets too cute okay draw
I guess it is a draw
it is a draw yeah and he found only
moves
um okay GG
GG
the path forward from 2000 is is filled
with uh trials and tribulations all
right let's analyze
so we will check his accuracy obviously
not trying to imply anything just
because people in the chat are curious
my accuracy was probably pathetic
it was 94.3 to 94.7 okay that's pretty
high actually for both of us so I did
not play terribly that's your answer to
the question I did not play terribly
here's the proof
okay that is some high accuracy for sure
I feel like got akomsky here
now a couple of words because this is an
extremely touchy subject
and people on YouTube especially I found
get can get very emotional about the
situation where a GM or somebody with a
platform
essentially just without proper judgment
or consideration is essentially implying
that if anybody lower rated than them
beats them their ego can't take it and
so by definition someone is cheating
now here's what I have to say on that of
course when a GM is playing an FM in
three plus zero it's unacceptable to
just go around and start throwing out
accusations now it's a different
situation the the higher the rating
disparity the less likely it becomes
that in a longer game you know for
example if a 1500 beats me in a 15
minute game and I'm playing completely
seriously
by definition that is probably
suspicious unless I had a mouse slip or
I blundered a queen if I'm playing my
strength for a 1600 or even a 2000 to
play like a 2600 for the entirety of the
game
if it's not some sort of opening Theory
you know or some Force draw is
suspicious by definition which doesn't
mean that the person is necessarily
cheating it's just statistically
unlikely hopefully people can understand
that phrase is not very controversial so
the game has to be investigated more
carefully
if the accuracy is like 95 you know
2000s rarely attain that so you have to
take the game consider the game very
seriously
the other thing that struck out to me
was how quickly my opponent was playing
which was almost instantly
and the other thing that stuck out to me
was the feeling I got that no matter
what I did my opponent had an accurate
response prepared so I definitely got
those feelings I'm not gonna lie I had
those feelings of helplessness that I
often get when I feel like I'm getting
you know when I'm playing a guide
um so am I a little bit just a little
bit suspicious yes and hopefully I don't
get burned at the stake for saying that
it would it be acceptable to just bury
my opponent and say he's cheating for
sure more than unacceptable
um so hopefully we can
we can tow that line and we can look at
the game with an engine and a couple of
the critical moments I want to see if in
fact they were top engine moves that's
going to be the goal and we're going to
look at the game and try to learn from
it that's the main goal
it's no okay I I can tell that some
people haven't listened to a single word
that I said
because you're saying isn't
statistically unlikely just a fancy way
to name cheaters no it statistically
unlikely means statistically unlikely it
means it happens from time to time
but if it happens it needs to be
investigated carefully that's all it
means
and no I know some people are going to
be listening to this thing yeah he
actually thinks this guy cheated for
sure he's just putting on a face no I
truly do not know I promise I swear I I
honestly do not know what to think
you know because part of me is saying
yeah like I just got totally outplayed
by 2000 the other part of me is like I
probably didn't play that well and get
over it
okay
here we go so the opening we have faced
before Bishop E2
this line with D4 has been played by a
lot of GMS but it's not particularly
great C5 is the top move so C5 is the uh
is the top engine Choice apparently this
is the way to fight the line see I never
knew that because in my day everybody
would play Bishop F5
and then after Knight F3 white is a
modest a small and modest Advantage so
for the purp yeah for the purposes of
this analysis I will turn on
I will turn on uh the chess.com engine
all right so you can see here that it's
like 0.2 I mean it's it's a very modest
advantage
it's a very modest advantage
but I like White's position I mean this
is relatively easy to play castles
black can play night before in such
positions but you can always go Knight
A3 and then chase the night away with C3
so C5 is uh is a great move here because
it immediately contests White Center
immediately contests towards Center so
we decided on playing C4
the Knight drops back to F6 and D5 okay
so E6 is obvious and very good on takes
E6 yeah so here I I simply fail to
understand that pawn take C6 is so
strong hopefully I can be forgiven for
that I operated out of general
principles I thought this was a very bad
move because this Pawn is very weak I
mean just visually it looks very ugly
but I think there are two factors that
contributed to my misevaluation the
first one is what I mentioned in a bit
which is that black has this idea of
ensconcing a knight on D4 and because we
don't have an E Pawn and because our C
Pawn is on C4 white is gonna permanently
have problems sorry white is going to
permanently have problems with the D4
Square my bad white is going to
permanently have problems uh with it
with the D4 Square
the second thing is of course the
semi-openf file which I also experience
problems with much like in openings like
the Vienna
you get the f file which you can use to
attack Black's King and it's a one-way
street because one side does have a Pawn
on the f file and the other side doesn't
and while not having a Pawn on the f
file can be considered a drawback here
our pieces are not active enough to
punish black for that it's more of a
strength
uh so Bishop takes E6 I correctly
evaluated and I thought that this was
quite a bit better for white uh and it
is I mean we're gonna play Bishop E3 and
queen side Castle
you know but given how obscure Bishop E2
is I really would doubt that this is
theory
so our opponent plays F6 c66 very
instructive Knight C6 Knight F3 Bishop
E7 castles castles this is all very
normal Bishop to G5
apparently already you know white is
struggling to equalize H6 good move
Bishop H4 and again I completely met 9h5
to me was not intuitive at all because
in my eyes
black is essentially leaving himself
with a bad Bishop what I fail to
appreciate is that this Knight coming to
F4 is just an incredibly strong idea
best move
Bishop B7 Queen E7 already probably
white is slightly worse so G3 I made a
very good move here second move
according to the engine the top engine
move here was Bishop to D3
and Bishop E4 so this is a little bit
computer-ish but keeping the bishop this
way would have kept equality
so G3 is a move that we played
essentially out of desperation because I
was so worried about the Knight coming
into F4 Rook Ada good move
rookie one
okay and Knight F6 another move that did
not occur to me at all
okay I'm starting to get a little bit
suspicious I will be completely and
totally honest here
but Knight F6 to me is not intuitive
because I I felt like black really wants
to go Knight F4 and also it's very
important to foresee that after Knight
H4 black has Knight to F4
black as Knights F4 yeah because of the
speed that's why I'm a little bit
suspicious because these moves are
taking black 15 to 17 seconds these are
extremely high level moves Bishop F1
Bishop E8
Queen C1 Knight G4
Bishop G2 oh so Knight D4 is the top
move okay Knight T4 which I thought was
a mistake but of course what do I know
uh take Stakes 94.
Bishop C6
is not accurate
or it is accurate sorry it's one of the
top moves
uh Bishop C6 is a good move
Queen to D2 I mean I'm defending very
well now here I think black made a
mistake here our opponent thought for a
while for two minutes and made a serious
mistake
of course the best move as I had
indicated is Knight G4 to E5
and the reason this move is so strong
the reason this move is so strong is
because the Knight is heading for F3 now
why is Knight F3 such a strong idea well
because it eliminates the only defensive
piece on the king side
here for example if light plays B3 then
after Knight F3 check as you can see
this is a very nasty position I would
even estimate this as more than minus
0.7 because you can see how weak the
light squares are on the king side
so very instructive retreating move
Knight E5 and Knight F3 of course if
white tries to cover the F4 F3 Square
then you give up a Pawn on C4 and the
Knight jumps into E3
so it's uh
it's a good idea to file into your
mental directory so Bishop takes E4 kind
of lets us off the hook but then our
opponent follows up very accurately Rook
F2 of course I did not see uh the fact
that the Knight is heading for C2 and I
correctly decided to take on E3 Knight
C2 here is winning for black rookie six
Queen f8 and you're gonna lose the Rook
on A1 and the pawn is just gonna run
forward so
this was the correct decision by me but
once again I start getting outplayed
Queen E2 E5
Rook F1 Queen C6 and already it's a
little bit worse King H3 E4
yeah B3 I'm still playing very
accurately here Queen G4 Queen E5
um Rook F5 is probably a step in the
wrong direction now Queen F4 is a slight
inaccuracy because of rookie 8 now Queen
E6
Rook d8
yeah still I'm holding equality
I'm still playing almost perfectly
but somewhere here I made a mistake
yeah C5 is still equal
but I had to find before
I didn't think the oh I saw before which
leads to immediate liquidation
but I forgot that after Rook A4
instructive moment ba obviously blunders
The Rook but you get the Rook onto a
square with check then you play ba
then you play ba
and uh it's a draw I mean it just it's
just Mutual liquidation and a two on two
when all is said and done the point is I
forgot that you can move the Rook onto a
defended Square
now what was the idea of the move C5 I
actually think this was a very ingenious
research
uh research why did I say that word
resource resource yeah that's why that's
why I misspoke I was like what word was
I planning to say
okay resource now it makes sense uh it
was an ingenious resource because if
black plays Rook B2 which I think is a
move a lot of people would make Rook B4
and white wins the pawn like you defend
and simultaneously attack and now you
see why I put the pawn on C5 so that B6
can be met with CB same thing by the way
after Rook A3 you go Rook before and
white is already playing for a win but
somehow I forgot the black and just stop
it with A5 Rook D4 and another very I
could King E8 not King E7 as I would
have played but King E8 of course King
F4 Rook H2
Rook F2 check
Rook C2
Rook B2 is an inaccuracy I guess
Rook C3 was the move
which to me is pretty intuitive Rook C3
but I was planning King D6 and
apparently black is close to winning
here
okay uh let's see if I defend it
accurately Rook B2 Rook D3 Rook G2
Rook G3 and already this lets me off the
hook due to B4 here for sure our
opponent is
I mean this is quite easy to draw at
this point but still not already like
already black has to be very accurate
black has to be very accurate here
yeah I mean it was a game played on a
Grand Master Level by black that's all
I'm gonna say the game was played at a
GM level
so if it's a Smurf then I believe it if
it's someone extremely underrated I
believe it otherwise I don't really
believe it
and of course there are more advanced
tools to checking I would especially
look at my opponent's other games but
the time consumption for such a game of
this quality is crazy I mean the guy has
to be ultra talented he let he ended the
game with 12 23. he really only thought
on one move funnily enough that move was
the only mistake of the game okay there
were some inaccuracies
um by the way the reason you play King
E8 here and not King to E7 is because is
because well his other games are on this
level clearly is because here white
plays Rook D6
and the point is after Rook A3 Rook B6
A4
Rook takes B7 is a check now compare
this to the king E8 line I was wanting
to play Rook D6 but I realized that if
you follow the same line this is not a
check black plays Rook takes B3 check
and wins the game on the spot because
this forces a rook trade and as a
consequence the pawn rolls down to
promotion
so something that would probably take me
you know a minute to appreciate it took
our opponent 15 seconds but it's pretty
consistent uh with his play if King E6
Instead This is even worse because here
The Rook gets to B6 with tempo
no I'm sure I mean he's if he's had an
accountant for years then he's legit but
it's just I mean again hopefully even if
you're my opponent and you're watching
this surely you can see why I'm starting
to get suspicious about this game a lot
of games a lot of moves on on a super GM
level for sure
so conclusions from this game and we
didn't analyze it quite as diligently as
I normally would analyze the speedrun
game you know sometimes this this
deflating feeling it makes it hard for
me to analyze the rest of the games look
nothing like this apparently yeah so
first of all
D4 C5 was Ultra accurate opening play
Ultra accurate opening play every move
about 15 seconds
then F take C6 is a super GM move right
here I this is a move that shows a very
high level understanding of the position
then
then of course super accurate play in
the middle game Knight H5 was a nice
move Rook d8 Bishop E8
9g4 Knight T4 I mean just perfect play
in the middle game then the one mistake
which was uh not to play 95 which was to
take on e4 but that was followed up by
another Ultra accurate sequence of Moves
Like every one of these moves was the
most testing I held my ground very
nicely I thought until I played C5 this
is where I started playing for a win and
the moment I start playing for when I
get into some trouble
black plays well and of course it would
have been more trouble if black had
played in this position either King to
E7 which to me was one of the most
intuitive moves of the whole game to
just bring the king up and prevent
White's King from accessing D6 and
instead Rook B2 allowed us to drop the
Rook back to D3 which opened up more
Pathways for our King
and
okay B4 was an accurate defensive move
and I was able to hold the game
um so I thought it was a well-defended
game
I could feel pretty early that we were
dealing with a very serious opponent I
had that feeling
you know again
you know when these come out on YouTube
there's always a buzz in the comments
section
and there's always some people who are
going to be like who are going to feel
like I'm unfairly judging my opponent or
I'm not giving him the benefit of the
doubt I am I'm not going to report him
I'm gonna take a closer look at the game
on my own
and if I feel that it's getting more and
more obvious then
you know that I might also I'm doing a
speed run and obviously I'm not
uh
you know I'm also smurfing so I don't
think it's really my place to report
people in the speedrun
uh unless unless it's Ultra blatant
cheating
okay I hope you enjoyed the analysis I'm
going to get going and watch the game
I'm gonna get going and watch the game
and uh I might be back tonight if I'm
feeling energetic I'll be back tonight
thank you everybody for the support and
for being very wholesome you know with
the 105 subs today it was a massive sub
day so thank you everybody uh very very
much particularly anur for all of your
support through the months
and velvet Canyon thank you for the five
Subs earlier as well I will raid who
will I raid I will raid
let's rate cost yeah let's rate Costa
and and keep the chess education content
going see you guys later uh thanks again
and goodbye
[Music]